- We are almost outta time,
but I have one more
important story to share.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
So as you know,
this is the part
of the show
where I usually surprise someone
with a thousand dollars,
courtesy of our friends at Pilot Pen.
Typically, it's a guest from
a post I found on social,
but sometimes,
I get to surprise a member of the audience
like this moment from a few weeks ago.
(swooshing sound)
Who's got it?
Who's going shopping, y'all?
(audience cheers)
How do you think you're
gonna spend that money?
- Concert tickets!
- Yeah!
(audience cheers)
what a great answer.
- And I've never seen you in concert,
so maybe if there's a show sometime
down the road, maybe...
- I don't know,
maybe there might be one coming up.
I dunno,
(audience groans)
I can't say it,
- [Lily] That's who I'd see.
- but you might be able to use it.
I'm gonna plan for that.
(audience cheers)
(Lily laughs)
- So, that was Lily.
And what I couldn't tell her at the time
was something, I'm so excited,
and have been waiting to announce, today.
So I asked her to dial us in.
So what's up Lily?
(audience cheers)
- Hi.
- Hi! So have you
- How's it going?
- It's going well.
So have you spent the money yet?
- Not yet.
As as you know,
I'd prefer to spend it on concert tickets.
So, I've got a few in
my head right now and,
like you said,
I feel like there might be
something coming with you,
so...
- Oh, that's so interesting.
So you are literally one of the first,
to know this.
I'm going to be playing
an exclusive Las Vegas engagement
this July 28th
(audience cheers)
through August 19th at Bakkt Theater,
Planet Hollywood.
I'm only doing,
10 shows.
I could only commit to 10 shows.
That's why it's exclusive.
There's only 10 shows.
I ain't addin' more.
I'm telling you right now,
Mama needs a little bit
of minute of a break.
So "Chemistry, an Intimate Evening"
is something you can only see in Vegas.
It's just for this show.
Just for these 10 shows.
And tickets go on sale this Friday
at TicketMaster.com/KellyVegas.
So Lily, here is the cool news.
I hope it's cool for you.
If it's not, just pretend.
Not only are you going to get to see
my brand new Las Vegas engagement,
you won't have to spend
a dime of that money
that you got here
because we are hooking you up
with two tickets to the show,
(audience applauds)
a two-night hotel stay
at Planet Hollywood Resort & Casino,
and round-trip flights
for you and a guest.
So you're comin' in style, Lily!
- Thank ya!
I'm gonna take my mom!
She's never been to Vegas.
- Oh! Yes!
Bring your mom!
I'm gonna bring my mama too
I'm gonna make her have
a little drink too.
- [Lily] Oh, yeah!
- Okay.
Thank you so much, Lily.
We're liking your post right now.
(audience applauds)
(bell dings)
- And that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, Makers of Friction,
the go to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want you to attend even more
concerts this year, Lily.
So they're giving you an
additional thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
You get a thousand
- What?
- [Kelly] more dollars.
- Gawd!
- Yeah, Lily!
Enjoy that money, girl!
Go see some shows!
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Jeff Goldblum, Chase
Stokes, Megan Piphus Peace,
and the Mildred Snitzer Orchestra.
Y'all have a great day, if it's not,
try and change it.